foreign
607 and every Friday for Black History
Month here on good day we'll be sharing
the stories of people who've really made
a difference here in our community the
National Coalition of 100 black women
for example makes history every day it
advocates for black women at home and in
the footsteps of the White House that's
right Nevada's chapter was started by Dr
Sandra Mack who worked until a recent
death to promote Equity our Candace
Charles shares her story
there was an imbalance our kids were not
being educated
women weren't giving proper health care
and laws and things weren't
provide it for us Terry Yates with the
National Coalition of 100 black women
tells me that in Nevada in 2004 longtime
educator and Advocate Dr Sandra Mack saw
this imbalance he wanted to better the
community that year Dr Mack started the
Nevada chapter of the National Coalition
of 100 black women non-profit National
Organization aimed at supporting and
uplifting black girls and women to
really be there for families for
children and to help uplift everyone
Congressman Stephen hartsford who at the
time was at the culinary Training
Academy remembers Dr Mack's ability to
feel the community with a sense of
purpose he tells me he was proud to
stand next to them in their work in the
community providing scholarships and
mentoring particularly in its history
right with supporting women when they
didn't always have that support whether
it was in the community whether it was
in their workplace whether it was in
politics a member of the NAACP the Urban
League League Delta Sigma data sorority
Inc and more Dr Mack's husband Danny
tells me supporting our community was
part of her nature it's just been a
passion all her life taking that passion
to the legislative floor in Washington
D.C she led the Coalition in fighting
for bills the impacted black women talk
to the legislators and say hey these
bills are important to black women they
just felt that there's somebody they
could count on and that would be the
sentiment amongst the community until
she was diagnosed with a gallbladder
cancer this year it was rough
at the counter she really wanted the
chemo she passed away the weekend before
her appointment for chemo I don't know
all of what she confronted during uh the
final days and weeks of her life but I
know that she lived a very fulfilling
life because she touched so many people
what Legacy do you hope that Dr Mack
leaves behind she did it out of the
goodness of her heart and that's the
part that I like Candace Charles 8 News
Now
a celebration of Dr Mack's life is being
held tomorrow morning at 11 o'clock
inside the New Jerusalem Worship Center
nearly 200 people are expected to attend